Are you guys ready to get kicked
in the emotions?
Well, tomorrow is the 77th
birthday of possibly the best
known Christian Republican
martial arts-turned Internet
meme, Charles Norris.
>> Ooh.
>> HARDWICK: Uh, sometimes know
as Chuck.
(applause and cheering)
There he is.
These days, Chuck-- seen here
deciding which audience member
to punch through the screen--
spends his days relaxing on his
Lone Wolf Ranch and selling his
new brand of bottled water--
CFORCE.
(laughter)
That's a real thing.
Chuck makes his own water by
punching clouds and making
nature cry.
(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
And...
CFORCE!
I got to believe "CFORCE" was
also his Wu-Tang name.
Right? That feels like that's
probably a thing.
(laughter)
Let's see.
Which one is he?
Oh, there he is.
>> He's in the middle.
>> HARDWICK: Now to us, Chuck
will always be the Internet's
ultimate badass, with Chuck
Norris facts detailing how Chuck
Norris once beat a wall at
tennis, and "Chuck Norris can
strangle you with a cordless
phone."
But at 77, Chuck is well into
Old Man Logan territory.
So, comedians, I would like you
to give me an Old Man Chuck
Norris fact.
Anyone can buzz in.
Matt Braunger.
>> Chuck Norris lowers his
cholesterol... to the ground by
punching it in the face!
>> HARDWICK: Yeah. Very good.
Points.
(applause and cheering)
Nick Simmons.
>> When he pees, it burns...
through the center of the earth.
>> HARDWICK: Yes, points.
(applause and cheering)
Very good.
Colton.
>> Yeah, Chuck Norris's balls
don't get lower as he ages.
They get higher.
They're currently under his
chin.
(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
He can tea-bag himself.
(laughter)